here's my question do I need to call
Ozzy to talk about you and Brad Pitt oh
and you've gone viral because of your
first question to mr. Pitt the world the
Internet everyone is waiting they're
hoping for this moment where you and
Jennifer run into each other so they can
take their picture I'll run into Jen
she's a good friend yeah so they can oh
you know how this goes the second the
second most important reunion of her
year exactly you know how that works
playing friends and then they were
saying that anyway Brad hit the red
carpet 35 minutes after Jen but inside
they set pretty close about 10 feet
apart they hit two of the same after
parties and were even spotted in the
same pic Brad drank water and ate Chex
Mix Jen hung out with Sandra Bullock
Brad Pitt and who doesn't love Jen's
reaction when Brad won Best Supporting
Actor that's her clapping right behind
Leonardo DiCaprio who got a big shout
out from his co-star I also have to
thank my partner in crime
LD she he's an all-star he's a gent and
I wouldn't be here without you man I
thank you still I would have shared the
raft for the record Brad it was actually
a door and you know what that Pitt
DiCaprio bromance goes back almost 25
years but now they better make room for
mrs. OH
it's all about me and you started you
know usually anyone stands next to me
watch usually reported as oh well here's
my real question were the same age how
come you still have all that damn here I
don't know but I got other problems
do you remember the last time you were
here nominated 22 years ago for your
greatest role ever I really am happy to
be nominated what would you tell that
girl 22 years ago there was wandering on
the carpet like oh I did this little
movie Selena who lost that day I don't
give up don't give up keep going it
doesn't matter what happens tonight
you're still a winner you shut up
JLo and a rod had the lock on cutest
couple holding hands on the red carpet
just an hour after he shared her pre
globe workout and while The Hustler lost
Best Supporting Actress to Laura Dern
she has plenty to celebrate starting
with the Super Bowl halftime show I'm
ready are you ready yeah I'm ready I'm
excited about it yeah I mean it's me and
Shakira she's carrying half the load I
feel good oh so you're like I'm good I'm
good
can we talk for a second about this
wedding we are planning it that's all I
can say we're planning it for sometime
this year will the kids have a hand and
worse of course can't have without the
kids we're not just getting married
we're making a family well you already a
family aren't yes
[Music]